Street y7 ebowley Street West 7a Mabel
the gun was shot fired at B Street in
West Emmett one of the residents shot a
gun in the air free time baseball cap
damn jacket light blue jeans about fifty
years of age last contact was you
standing on the corner then disconnected
color hear any gunshots okay
ketchup or can you call him back and
seem to have any further direction
negative no number just about giving it
hey you guys are new gunshots none at
all but no vengeance all right we had a
ton of shootings growing up here and
we're hearing them all the time and it
wasn't just like single gunshots they
were machine guns going off so I grew up
knowing the machine gun shots as street
sweepers cuz that's what my dad always
called for decades Richmond California
has had a reputation for violence in
2007 this city of a hundred thousand
people had 47 homicides
it was one of the highest murder rates
in the country lately for three ever but
by 2012 homicides had fallen from 47 to
18 how be it happen
for the first time in years it seems
like pieces possible
we could get the young people sorry
reaching out for the young people and
getting them to walk seven years ago I
lost a baby brother to gun violence here
he was 18 years old he was on his way
home from work and he was shot 42 times
we don't want to lose more young black
and brown men like him who were innocent
the homicides have been driven by feuds
between young men in North Central and
South Richmond they've divided the city
along invisible lines
more like you're like a Turk me I want a
phone from the north side of Richmond
over there I decided a knife is central
another side Center a South Side people
that's in the madness to the confusion I
would say I know say like gang and then
war it's a war it's a confused war the
people that's in the confused war they
have the limits to where I can go
growing up my neighborhood like I jumped
around a lot from where I remember my
neighborhood was always just fishes it
always had the cycle of violence but
once a pod of time it wasn't as much
killing it was more of feeding the fam
and having money than gonna just kill
back and forth back and forth back and
forth I'm a slide time itself I came
back out to Richmond in high school and
it was alright I was going to school
with par Chester village kids central
kids off Richmond kids remember wheels
are cool but after high school is when
things started getting shaky most dudes
don't know what they want to do with a
life after high school so what do they
do go hang out in the neighborhoods and
once you start being around the cast
that never was doing nothing in the
first place influenced you to get with
the same situation anyway
you find I go over here and do something
to somebody you ride you know and that's
how some guys get caught up prior to
2002 2001 a lot of what was going on was
really based on drugs in the underground
market the assaults were much more
directed folks knew that they were
coming verses today random
you
you got a lot of independent contractors
out there trying to earn respect but
also trying to protect themselves
they've got to carry their guns and
they've got to be prepared that someone
from another side of town might roll
into their neighborhood and shoot them
simply because of geography in 2006 as
homicides spiked richmond hired chris
Magnus from Fargo North Dakota to
transform the police department Magnus
argues that community engagement is key
to preventing homicides so what I'd like
to share with you is what a
high-capacity magazine can do when it's
being fired on a Main Street surrounded
by neighborhoods and this is what it
sounds like at stege and cutting in the
city of Richmond
I think there were a lot of us who
started to recognize that we had to do
more than just make the arrests and the
traffic stops and we had to build a
whole new level of engagement and
relationships with residents it sounds
so easy but it's not I mean it and it
means doing some things that don't
necessarily come naturally to police
officers you have to get out of the
police car you have to be talking to
people you have to be listening to
people you have to do relentless follow
up are they gonna identify you know what
if they do so there would be no
fingerprints or anything like that it is
cold so a lot of people coming over here
right now
you know all these people my house right
here
hey no sir first I was all right okay
yeah it was the hose in the house saw
two people in their house when they saw
them they took off running and from
there he gave description Oh someone in
the Raiders act here this is hard to
believe me because I mean
we live okay you know yeah I have a good
income his mom has a good income
understand I mean it may not have been
him it could've been his buddy just him
hanging out with his buddy right yeah
because some of his buddies probably
aren't is is lucky as him I understand I
understand buddy he has to make better
decisions on he does on on who hang with
when the hang with him and that's where
you come in I'm not trying right yeah
and the issues not with us either right
man let me tell you you know I I um I
used to have a different outlook you
know about probably super dumb should
I'm glad you around appreciate that
but by the fall of 2006 it was clear
that the police alone weren't enough
residents camped out to demand more the
city created the office of neighborhood
safety or ons to focus exclusively on
gun violence they work directly with the
young men involved who we deal with on a
large part are young people who neither
had anyone who were positive are trusted
anybody who was trying to get close to
them and we've caught them at 18 19 20
years old maybe live in 20 years not
trusting anybody
oh no in CA McCullar nah see cuz my
nickname it has to be fitting the owner
me yeah I mean I don't want to be called
you know look crazy cuz I Know Who I am
right okay so no no no we want some
casual some casual you walk with him you
talk with him you spend time with him if
you have a shepherd who doesn't smell
like cheap then something's wrong with
them you know just had a situation the
other night where a young man had a
situation where his mom and his younger
sister were robbed at gunpoint his
default mindset was I'm getting ready to
go take care of the situation myself but
because of the relationship we've been
able to build as a result of the office
he made a phone call and say hey this is
what I'm thinking about enrichment
murders came in clusters as victims
families sought vengeance in his first
two years the ONS tried to prevent
through street outreach but by 2009 it
was clear that wasn't enough the chief
of police comes in with Davone and
introduces him to the group and
basically tells us work with him and we
didn't know what the office of
neighborhood safety was or who he was so
we were I was skeptical something
happened where I was able to get into a
room with our police department and I
began to hear a conversation amongst
them where they believed that maybe 15
people were responsible for 70% of the
homicides and shootings in 2009 now I
knew it but I couldn't prove it and I'm
not sure if you understand what that
means and law enforcement a lot of times
we know things but because we know
something doesn't mean that we have a
prosecutable case I ask a very raw
question a very basic question share
with me who you all believe will be dead
in the next six months share with me who
you think are the people that are gonna
be responsible they were the same people
on both sides of the coin
so essentially who are the catalyst who
are the instigators who are the current
active firearm offenders who are out
free walking the streets of Richmond
right now Boggan sent his staff out to
invite those young men to City Hall and
offer them a deal the ONS would pay them
a stipend and help them with basic goals
like getting a driver's license GED or
healthcare in return they asked them to
stop shooting when you you clearly
articulate to them they're promoting
amongst themselves self genocide you're
killing yourselves because not only were
87 percent of the young men who died on
the streets of Richmond looking like you
black and brown young men they were more
than likely killed by someone who looks
like you two and quite frankly what
sense
ah does that make its when he was
letting us know that thing bares me in
the way cuz it's like man seemed like we
just out here some savages and we're not
cutting home life and I know a lot of
people around me not to it's just an
environment you ant-man's like we was
born in this and this is what we know
and we know cuz out here you can you can
you can't have a hard work will let me
rephrase that you can have a heart but
you can't show it
the most dramatic change was around what
happened in their lives I mean I sigh
watch these people who I knew or
involved in violence stop shooting what
what I found unique about OH&S is that
they are actually working with the
people who caused the violence you see
these young men out there on the street
people are afraid of them and it's hard
to help someone who terrifies you
keep your hands out of your pocket it's
your pan out of your pockets along with
you or have you had an experience we